y ya de por si va a ser una toma de
posesión distinta debido a la pandemia
pero ahora hay temores de que washington
puede hacer una vez más escenario de
violentos enfrentamientos atendiendo al
llamado de las autoridades locales y
antes de presentar su renuncia en la
tarde de este lunes el secretario
interino de seguridad nacional chat wolf
anunció que el dispositivo de seguridad
estará listo antes de lo planeado a la
luz de los eventos de la semana pasada y
el programa de seguridad de cara a la
toma de posesión así como la
recomendación del director de servicios
secretos james murray e instruido al
servicio secreto de eeuu para que
empiece las operaciones de seguridad
nacional especial federal para la toma
de posesión de 2021 el miércoles 13 de
enero en vez del 19 de enero a la alerta
que lanzó en días pasados la alcaldesa
de washington merrill de bowser se ha
sumado el gobernador de maryland temen
por que se repita una escena que no se
veía desde hace más de dos siglos la
toma violenta de la sede del congreso y
los muchos de nuestros departamentos de
policía y de todo el estado y la guardia
nacional siempre han estado involucrados
en las tomas de posesión esta es
obviamente una
mucho más grave ya tenemos alrededor de
500 miembros de la guardia nacional en
la ciudad hemos reforzado nuestra
presencia policial y creo que enviaremos
varios cientos de guardias más modernas
anders ante las advertencias del fbi y
de posibles protestas armadas en la
capital la guardia nacional autorizó el
envío de hasta 15 mil tropas incluso se
prohibirá que los turistas visiten el
monumento a washington al menos hasta el
24 de enero según el buró de
investigaciones hechos de violencia
similares estarían planeando pse en los
50 capitolios estatales de cara a la
posición del nuevo presidente joe biden
dice que el tema de su inauguración será
la unificación del país y asegura no
tener miedo de tomar juramento en
exteriores como es